veuillez s'il-vous-plaît décliner votre
identité
je vous demande d'accueillir rené la
renverse
que saviez vous de monsieur li avant de
le rencontrer je savais que c'était un
batteur de mötley crüe comme eux trouvé
séduisant si j'adorais sans sourire
et je les aime tous genres
on est faits l'un pour l'autre mona à
l'amour éternel
nous sommes récemment entrés en
possession du mage très intéressante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ne
super ti au regard d'un truc qu'on
n'aurait jamais dû voir
personne n'a jamais fait fortune avec la
sextape une célébrité et si on la
vendait tout en restant anonyme un site
web un site quoi c'est un truc sur
ordinateur où les gens pourraient nous
commander directement la vidéo
fait tellement c
qu'est ce que c'est c'est rick howard
combien de copies qui circulent des
dizaines peut-être
des copies pirates fleurissent partout
sur le web t'as pas l'air de comprendre
à quel point c'est important je suis
autant bois sur sa figure mais c'est
plus grave pour moi commencer à plus
grand pour toi
qui
on attend que schwab elle est parfaite
et vous vous sentez dans l'obligation de
plaire à tout le monde chaque seconde
mais non
[Musique]